ramsay show you can be intentional about
your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice christie
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we take your questions about your
life
and about your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five chad starts off
this hour in minneapolis hi chad welcome
to the ramsey show
yeah thanks for taking my call dave and
chrissy
uh so a little backstory um
separated in divorce in 2020 um was able
to you know
contribute to all the bills through the
divorce late last year and was able to
pay off
30 grand in debt and actually paid off
my
all of the balance of my student loan
seven thousand dollars this morning so
i'm officially debt free good for you
that's awesome wow yeah so
2020 was was rough but we got through
some stuff um
so my my situation is i am currently
living in a
home owned by my by my company um
for free it's a great place i just cover
utilities i'm sort of a pseudo caretaker
of the house
with no with no plan to need to move off
of that
uh through the divorce uh i gained sole
possession of a rental
that we used to live in we only lived
there for about a year about seven years
ago
so i'm aware of that you know there's
probably
probably some long-term capital gains
tax um
on that i owe 45 it's worth about 105 so
capital gains on that i think is 20 of
about twelve or so twelve thousand
dollars
to i've got
i've got a great renter in there it's
actually my ex-wife's family who's
living in that house
and looking at with where real estate is
now
me not needing a place to live does it
make sense to sell the house pay the tax
put that money that i would make on that
into the market so that i have money for
a down payment in the future
wow there's a lot of crap going on there
all right uh uh yeah
i mean it to me it's actually moronic to
say my ex-wife's in-laws are living in
it and they're great renters
these things in the same breath he said
that in the same breath
and it's my ex-wife okay okay great
what's your definition of a great renter
they pay
they pay they're clean um i'm guessing
you have a good relationship
sort
um her myself and my and my ex-wife
family uh we
still get along really well so it wasn't
it wasn't like this terrible
this you know back and forth divorce you
know
we developed a nice guy like that so
he's a nice guy i mean this is
i mean this is great that's good i'm
happy that's okay yeah that's good
we're shocked we're shocked chad but
it's good it's good there's nothing
wrong with it
so you don't have a home uh that you
live in because your company that you
work for
furnishes you one you're 100 debt free
you have your emergency fund in place or
we'll have shortly what is your income
uh 105. okay plus a plus a
a a hot or cold
uh bonus annually in february okay so
got one this year but
but so generally speaking set aside the
whole drama of the divorce and the
in-laws and all that stuff
and just say okay we have a rental
property that we owe 45 000 bucks on
do i sell it i don't know why you would
well so the looking at you know let's
just say
three years ago so i'm i'm tired of that
company
if i were ever to if you ever needed a
house and you wanted to take the money
out of that house you could just sell it
then
right so what's the why why why sell it
now
well to because it's it's i don't know
that the house is ever going to be worth
more
and why wouldn't i could i and
well be this with with the market that
that i'm that i'm in
it's a it's a rural town um only about
500 people
um houses don't fly off the shelves
and i'm just looking at
would i make a better return on my money
is it an area of the city that is
blighted
i mean if you you wouldn't buy this
piece of real estate as an investment
were you buying real estate today
um it i it's not a it's not a great
area for buying buying real estate as an
investment
why
i don't know i guess maybe it is i i i
i bought it on a foreclosure um that's
not the point
why why you made a clear statement wise
it's possible that your statement's
correct i wasn't saying you're wrong i'm
just understanding why you're just
saying it's so rural
like it's a row house it's in inner city
house right oh
no no it's not an inner city it's a
rural rule
yeah i probably would not buy that as a
regular one
i wouldn't disagree with you driving 20
minutes to go to
walmart yeah there's not a vibrant
enough market for it to increase a lot
in value is what you're saying because
the market's not very big
so that's why you wouldn't that's why
you wouldn't buy it again okay
right so when is their lease up
so through i currently do not have a
lease with them
so so it's we've just been kind of
poking along at it what do they pay in
rent
700 is that market
uh yeah that's that's market okay uh the
mortgage
the mortgage on it is is um okay well
you know we got to take the whole thing
into consideration i'm not worried about
the in-laws because you're not
ex-in-laws because you're not so
uh but if with a standard tenant in
there or with them
i'm going to offer them a slight
discount on the rent
to stay in the property with a 30-day
notice
to leave which is what they have now and
because they don't have a lease and the
discount is to keep the property
sparkling clean and show ready because
we're putting it on the market
if they don't want the property to be
shown and they won't keep it sparkling
clean
for a slight discount in the rent and
continue with the 30-day notice promise
then they need to go ahead and leave and
you need to put it on the market
yeah i think uh i i think that's more so
i just wanted it yeah now how to
how to couch that in a conversation
where it doesn't feel like you're
hitting back from the divorce is an
interesting
discussion too right right
right yeah and that that's that's the
delicate balance is that you know
great so it's also it's also okay to
wait a fall to do this and let this
all get a little more water under the
bridge
if you want to be nice to if you want to
be super nice too right well
yeah so i mean but there's
you don't need the money and there's no
rush no i don't
you don't don't need the money it's but
but looking at could
if i if that money was in in a mutual
fund could i be looking at
10 because i'm not you know obviously
the longer they stay in the rental the
more principal that's
completely okay to move them now but the
closer to the divorce you move the more
they're going to interpret that as
hitting back
regardless of what you say because human
beings are just going to act that way
i think do you think yeah i think it
just yeah the the timing and the way
that you present it is going to matter a
lot yeah
and uh but there's no even what you
would make on it is there oh and by the
way your capital gains calculations
wrong you need to talk to your tax guy
it's not based on the equity in the
house it's based on
what you paid for it minus the
depreciation you've taken which is your
adjusted basis subtracting from your
sale price what you owe on it has
nothing to do with the calculation
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had chm chm saved our life
same document financial life christian
healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget-friendly option
and the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
host of a major podcast movement you
ought to check it out
it's the christy wright show go to
figure and uh it is absolutely exploding
be sure you join her
on there her devotional 40 day journey
back to you
living true 40 days to get back to you
is a best-selling
devotional that just came out back in
the fall and it has done
very very well thank you very much be
sure and check that out
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run
every month you'll save even more use
the promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from mason
in grand rapids my wife has a dream of
starting a wedding venue
on a rural piece of land and i had the
idea of combining my passion for
pheasant hunting into this project how
do we fund
buying the land and building a venue
i've actually gotten this question not
the pheasant hunting part
but the event venue on a piece of land
or
commercial space multiple times dave and
what i encourage people to do
that have never had any experience in
event planning or event hosting
to figure out how to prove their concept
on a smaller scale
so is there some type of event space
that you can sublease
to prove your concept get your get your
feet wet start to build your skills and
say okay this is what we need this when
we build when we buy
and then you're also going to get cash
in the door while you're proving the
concept to be able to fund
buying either the land or the building
or whatever it is that you want to do
but but people start with this big dream
and i love that because they
they have a big dream but i want them to
scale it back say what is the
a smaller version of that dream to baby
step into it to prove it
get some cash in the door and learn
along the way run
your point has run some kind of a
freaking test mark
yes yeah some way to get out there and
prove that you know how to do this a
little bit
so you know in order to open a
restaurant you do not have to
build right a restaurant right you you
start doing catering
out of your kitchen right and then from
there you once you've proven
some of that you've proven that a people
will eat your food and not die
right and that they want to buy it some
more then the next thing you do is you
talk about renting a defunct
restaurant somewhere for a little
nothing where all the equipment's in
there
only after you've been doing this a long
time do you build
a restaurant from the ground up as a
small business endeavor
and you know so much more by the time
you actually do that you know so much
more about what you need what you want
and what you're missing you might not
come out to the country to get married
well
pheasant hunting place the number one
thing i see people
believe one of the number one things
especially when they're starting out is
they they have this idea dave
that if you build it they will come yeah
it's a field of dreams
it's just not true if you build it and
you build something good and you try
really hard and you chase them down and
you have really good marketing and you
get really smart
if you do a lot of things you can go
find them and make this work but it's
not just i'm going to build an event
space on a farm where my husband
pheasant hunts and they're just going to
show up it doesn't work like that not
online or in person by the way
just because you put a website up
doesn't mean people are going to come to
it you have to
do more than that you have to be more
strategic so prove your idea on a
smaller scale
before you go buy some land yeah like
be a pheasant hunt guide on
other people's land or on your land with
no facilities required right
a day trip type of a thing before you
build a freaking lodge
yeah you know and um so make sure you
actually can find the birds son
yes you probably know salary wouldn't be
doing this uh but i mean you know and
prove that other people will pay you for
the privilege of hunting
beside you because you're going to lead
them into birds so
um the same thing so i don't know this
sounds like
uh two ideas that need a lot more work
and you're getting ready to go broke
screwing around with them if you go
build
build big build big buildings
with debt well and here you know i can
see 400 000
worth of facilities here that nobody
visits well and to your point which we
didn't even hit on this but these are
two separate ideas that have nothing to
do with each other other than the fact
that land is involved
and dave one of the things i see a lot
you might be a redneck
if you get married in a pheasant hunting
lodge okay
people because it's so easy to start a
side business which is what i love
helping people do through business
boutique it's so easy to start something
small on the side from home online
whatever
well because it's so easy dave people
act on all of their ideas they start 15
businesses they're like oh i do hair and
i do landscaping and i walk dogs and i
cook barbecue
and i'm also an optometrist on the side
and i do pheasant hunting and i do
wedding plans like
no one knows what you do you're not
known for anything
so pick one thing do it well these are
not related these ideas are not related
so if you wanted to do them all
conveniently at some point they're
marketed different you have separate
markets
separate brands separate purpose
separate time frame no no bride wants to
walk down the aisle with
gunshot in the background it's just true
shotgun wedding
it's a true shotgun wedding it takes on
a totally different meaning yes it does
all right so yeah um
i mean you could hypothetically back
into
ending up with an event barn on the
property that had some lodging
that could be used for both but they
really don't overlap these are not
i mean you'd really have to push this so
um
so mason i start small somewhere else
don't be building buildings for brand
new businesses
because you're wrong about what you
think the thing about business you can
always there's three rules of business
and they always stand true
here they are it's going to take twice
as long as you think it's going to cost
twice as much as you think and you're
not the exception
those are the three rules of business
yeah and so uh because you get all
hyped up and piped up and i do too i get
all jammed up about my latest
entrepreneurial idea that i had
when i was walking this morning
listening to an audiobook and i went i
can do
and then all of a sudden you figure out
a million dollars later you were wrong
so uh yeah i
yeah take your time and uh proof
text it yep find a way to
test your ideas in the market
ah lucinda is with us lucinda is in
charlottesville virginia hi
lucinda how are you hi dave how are you
better than i deserve what's up
wonderful um so i
am currently ten years into my current
career
for which i took out a student loan um
and my student loan is currently in
collections
um i never really understood the
difference between like default
i mean forbearance and uh deferment
so now it's landed in collections and i
wonder if i can negotiate
my student loan down back to like its
original
price this is a federally insured
student loan
yes okay no
the principal balance that you borrowed
is not negotiable
and the interest that has been charged
on it is not negotiable
the late fees are negotiable and any
other
gotcha fees other than interest and
principle might be negotiable but
by and large the most of the number that
you're looking at are your principal and
your interest because you've really not
paid anything on it for 10 years what do
you owe
about 38 000 and what do you make
about 38 thousand okay all right what do
you do
i do uh coding and billing medical
coding and billing
okay 40 hours a week
40 yes okay you work for someone or
contract
i work for someone for a company okay
um are you prohibited from taking in
more work as a side job
no actually i'm actually ready to do
that i had a part-time job
uh before colbit and then you know covet
came and so i
had lost that job so if you find
yourself if you took on 30 more hours a
week of work of billing and coding what
could you make a month
about couple grand
maybe a little less than that 30 hours
30 hours a week worth
bring home a couple grand in a month
yeah oh yes yes definitely
definitely okay all right and so
uh to 2038
that gets us out of debt in less than 20
months right
yeah i'm i'm and i'm ready i just i've
been a little hesitant to call
you know and speak with these people
because i know once i give them
information
everything will start over yeah if i
don't have the money the only reason you
need to give them
you don't need to give them any in for
any information you just need to get
information on exactly what your
balances are and try to negotiate away
any late fees
but not the interest in the principal
the reason they won't negotiate that
away is
the government has guaranteed they're
going to get that money from the
government if you don't give it to them
so there's no reason for them to
negotiate it down but get a solid number
and then start putting two thousand to
three thousand dollars a month on it and
you will be done in under two years
you have to address this issue now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
mark and kerry are joining us which can
only mean one thing
they're debt-free where you go guys yes
sir thank you for having us
absolutely our honor so how much have
you paid off
we were dollars and 89 shy of 150 000.
i'm going with 150 that's called it's a
rounding error
okay and uh how long did this take you
22 months
wow and your range of income during that
time just over a hundred to a hundred
and eleven thousand
cool what do you guys do for a living
i'm in sales and uh
she does the harder job taking care of
the kids in the household that'll do it
that'll do it where do you guys live uh
eleanor west virginia
uh near charleston huntington west
virginia beautiful area of the country
yes sir
beautiful mountains up there wow well
welcome to nashville
congratulations very well done
what kind of debt were you in 150
000 well um some people would say it's
dirt and some building materials but we
just call it our house
so ah you paid off
all mortgages oh look at the weird
people
these are amazing how old are you two
well when we did it one of us has since
turned 36 but we were both 35 when we
finished it off
okay all right way to go man and a paid
for house what's this thing worth
probably
250 275 somewhere in the ballpark
[Laughter]
oh you got no payments in the world
you're not even 40.
you rock that's right wow
that's amazing guys i love it so what
started this journey because most people
don't
i mean you're weird i mean just most
people don't think they can do this and
you just said i'm doing it
well um we've and i guess part of that
we had a little money we
at the end knocked out a big chunk that
we always sat on
thought it was our comfort and stuff and
finally had to get over putting it
you know where the money was going it
was still ours one way or another but
i guess going back a little while not to
get in too much of my job i love my job
and i love my bosses but their technic
their tactic of i guess being a sales
manager maybe was more of a
doom and gloom you know if we don't get
this done next month who knows what's
going to happen and i got to a point
where it was like
i don't want to rely on what may or may
not i want to know
what i control and uh at that point we
started and went after the house we said
we're getting this done
and if they try to use some of those
we're it kind of bounces off
you know right not that we're in trouble
when you don't have a mortgage yes sir
[Laughter]
yes sir i like it i like it that's fun
so how did you guys get connected to us
well uh this job that i was in when i
first started my career i had
kind of a small territory and part of it
was eastern kentucky and
there wasn't too many stations down
there uh one of them little
hick country station and you happen to
be on there
i fit right in i thought it might suit
you
but i ended up listening to it and
that's how we kind of got on board the
uh
and actually i'm not a huge reader i
read some if it's something that really
interests me
and actually my wife bought me the book
when i started talking about you
that kind of got us involved and kind of
took it off and we went from there but
probably on the house we slowed down as
far as we weren't totally focused and
then all of a sudden
like i said that kind of just ignited
the you know some of those things and we
decided we're going to get after it and
here we are
wow so did y'all have debt other other
consumer debt before you start paying
off the house when you
when you listen to the show no um when
early in our marriage we did just a
little bit but it was something that i
remember the first time we had a car
payment a long time ago
but it was something that never sat well
with us you know we paid off that one
and
you know i don't know 10 much just
because we wanted to get rid of it and
we
when then we never went with that and
never sat on it but like i said we kind
of
got focused and honed in on the house
yeah y'all been weird all along you're
just a little weirder now
i love that so carrie 22 months
you guys had to lean in and sacrifice
what was the hardest part of this
um i don't know if it was really that
hard in a lot of ways just because
i'm a real person so having the budget
was actually easier for me
and he would think you know i wasn't
interested but i just would say like
okay what is the budget for this what's
the budget for that and
so he said it and i just followed it and
so i mean
adding on to what she said as far as she
i said it she
implemented i mean one thing i wanted to
say was on stage
especially here the last few weeks i'm
not emotional type but i'm getting there
but
i've never been so humbled in knowing
what she did
when for probably the first 12 months i
didn't get it i mean i kept selling her
you got to be involved because you hear
the people that aren't both of them
meeting
we never met went over budget the whole
time she didn't care to look at it
the thing is she was more in than most
people even think about being in
you know she let me uh you know she
would tell me
tell me what my budget is and then
halfway through the month she goes how
much do we have left in groceries i'll
be like oh here it is
and she'd just keep it under and uh very
humbled by what she
what respect and trust she put in me to
lead us in the right direction
and i didn't want to fail her that's
part of the reason i kept pushing
to do it shorter and shorter and shorter
and you know we pushed harder to get to
the point that
plus i want to do it while she was still
i mean one of us was still 35.
he's wearing the older woman thing out
here let's see i'm older than matt
he's come on come on don't let him get
away with that kick him in the shin
it's only ten months that's about what
that's about how much older sharon is
than me so i'm married to an older woman
for about 10 months a year yeah that's
right yeah
matt's three months and he reminds me
during those three months on the
he's like well one of us oh he's two he
did two wow well it's good it's a good
trend then
all right way to go you guys we're very
proud of you so you have no
payments in the world no sir how does
that feel
good i'll let her answer go ahead
no it's good it's you know you didn't
realize what but it was a weight that
was lifted when
you know when it was over so it was it
was good to be done
yeah you feel free yes you do yeah and
and you don't realize it until you get
there what that feeling feels like you
know you're
because you're working you're working
and working and then when it's over
you're
like oh it does feel lighter yeah it's
almost surreal
yes it is well done very very well done
what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is what
did you all do the key things that made
this possible
to me it was all about focus which you
put your your focus on your sights i
think you had somebody under recently
talking about putting all guns on the
target
you know we were focused on
what our goal was and i'm pretty you
know she say i can get
single track minded you know i'm on i
didn't want tracks and i'll follow that
until the end you know to the station
we're getting to but
uh just being focused on what we were we
were going after and that's all we
we cared about it's amazing too because
when you started telling your story
you talked about you didn't want anybody
holding anything over your head or being
able to
to scare you with this situation or what
if this happens it's like
nobody has anything on you now you've
got all the power all the options in the
world
absolutely when you're debt-free it's
just that's exact that's one of the
things we try to help people understand
it's not just financial
it's also the sense of power and control
and options that that
financial freedom allows and you guys
have that well done y'all that's amazing
well as young as you are if you just
start investing just a house payment
from now on you'll be multi multi multi
millionaires yes sir i mean that alone
wow very cool so you changed your family
tree brought the kiddos with you what
are their names and ages
good mom we have landon is 10
and jalen is seven cool awesome so have
they been practicing
their debt-free scream do they know what
we're doing let's see the side on uh
well i don't know to your right side of
the stage have been practicing maybe the
other side
not so much they might join us we'll see
all right
very cool with our family trees changed
i'm proud of you guys
we got a copy of rachel cruz's book for
you know yourself know your money new
york times best seller
and hopefully that will help you out
guys out as you continue on your wealth
building journey very very very well
done
good stuff all right it's mark and kerry
landon and jalen from charleston west
virginia 150 thousand dollars paid off
in 22 months making 100 to 111
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
here we go three two one
[Applause]
oh you gotta love it congratulations
that's amazing
man house and everything everything 36
years old
i mean just like you said the options
the possibilities of what they can do
now
this young it turns out it's incredible
a lot of money
turns into a lot of money when you quit
making banks rich
the odd thing happens you make yourself
rich
amazing correlation this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well if there's one thing we all know by
now you cannot
invest alone you need someone in your
corner someone in your life
who knows the market knows about
investing
that can talk you off the ledge when
cove it happens
or whatever it is right look i love
do-it-yourselfers i'm a do-it-yourselfer
but i don't even work on my own cars
anymore and i certainly don't pull my
own teeth and i know a lot more about
investing than most of you
and i don't do my own investing i don't
do
get caught up in some reddit group
investing in game stock
gamestop uh you make rookie mistakes you
get greedy you lose your butt
and you get into all kinds of problems
it was fun to watch it was kind of an
interesting news story for about 36
seconds
but it's not an investment strategy
when i christy i remember um
you and rachel were probably little
girls and
beanie babies were crazy yeah yeah yeah
and um we consequently have
a lot of the grand babies play and the
dogs play with the beanie babies now
my mother-in-law just gave carter a
little hedgehog i was like where did
that come from she was like it's our
beanie baby collection that was going to
make us rich
yeah that's it that's it i had people
call me on the air saying
i'm moving my kids college funds into
beanie babies beauty babies
sure and i of course was not nice to
them and ripped them to shreds for being
so
dadgum foolish but this is the kind of
crap you do
you get caught up in whatever the latest
thing is i remember you know when
the iraqi dinar we're going to buy the
currency in
iraq a failed country which of course
makes it a very stable currency
what a dumb bud idea you know and people
do stuff like this
and they put money in things they
shouldn't put in that are fattish
or new or what listen don't do that
you're trying to you're trying to build
wealth so you need somebody in your
corner
and we have put together a group of
people we recommend called smart
investor pros cause you're a smart
investor and they're the pro to help you
and they're gonna teach you and you're
gonna understand investing and they're
going to calm your little butt down so
you don't do stupid butt stuff like
beanie babies does that sound absurd
sounds absurd and then the second round
was somebody told me that some of those
beanie babies my dog was playing with
were worth five thousand dollars on ebay
so i jump on ebay and they're selling
for they're listed for five thousand
dollars but no one's ever sold one
right sure listed but they're next year
i cannot find
any confirmed sale of beanie babies
over a hundred dollars in the last
decade
you can list anything for about anything
doesn't mean you can lose you yeah
my wife my wife is looking at a piece of
real estate she goes but they're asking
and i don't care what they're asking it
doesn't matter what they're asking it's
nothing with the value you can ask
anything so text of the word
invest to 33 789
if you're ready to do some investing
we'll hook you up with a smart vester
pro who will give you a
oh god a calm ala
boring steady
predictable result plan
which is the way you build wealth the
tortoise beats the hair
every time i read the book the hair is
running around all over the place
buying beanie babies but the tortoise is
slow and ugly
and wins text invest to 33
789 one thing i'm sure of not a single
smartvestor pro in the history of
our involvement has recommended beanie
babies as an outlet okay so
other than something for your baby kids
to play with or your baby dog to play
with that's simple
text invest to 33 789
invest 33789 and smartmister pro will
help you get
your stuff going for your baby step 4
retirement five kids college
your long-term wealth building tools all
of this stuff preston's in greenville
south carolina hi preston welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hey dave long time listener first time
caller
well thank you first of all first of all
i want to say hello to you and christy
and i want to thank you for help saving
my financial life
well bless your heart thank you sir how
can we help today yes sir well
this is it feels like a rhetorical
question and actually after hearing your
debt free scream it's both intimidating
and kind of inspirational because the
question i have
is i'm completely debt free except for
my house
and i only owe 80 000 on the house
so and i know it may sound crazy but i
just had to ask the question anyway
in about two years i could use my return
but my 401k to pay it off if i had to
but i feel like in the meantime i could
use the money that i made just to pay it
off
and i was just wondering is that a good
idea more than anything else
how old are you because at 59 and a half
in my state you can use your 401k so
you're
and a half give or take right okay and
how much is in your 401k today
uh what about two teams
okay and what do you make a year
uh i read about 80 000. good for you
well you've done real well
congratulations the two primary things
that we found
when our ramsey team did a study of the
largest study ever done
on millionaires in north america the two
primary things we found that they did
for their first
one to five million dollars in net worth
was
they got their home paid off that was a
big chunk of it
and they had a big chunk in retirement
savings so you're heading
correctly on both of these issues and so
anything we can do to get that house
paid off the fastest we can get it paid
off the faster you're going to build
wealth and the more wealth you're going
to build
so yeah you're going to go ahead and pay
that off in the next two years with your
income
sure yes that's the goal but i was just
i was just actually i said well i i feel
kind of silly asking no it's not it's
not silly at all it's a good question
it's a good question but my point is you
want you want a big bunch of
my point is you want a big bunch of both
at the end of the game a big bunch
of paid for house and a big bunch of
money piled up in your
uh investment account when you get there
so christy what we found was and he's
right on track to be there by the way
um was that these millionaires the
typical millionaire in their first
uh what was a in their first little bit
of wealth their first million to five
million dollars
had about a third of it in their home
was paid off
and a lot of them hit this model exactly
like a
statistically significant number and uh
and about two-thirds was in their 401k
or the roth ira so we find somebody with
a million and a half net worth
half a million paid for house and a
million in their 401k
and that we found that over and over and
over and over and over again
and he's he's really on track to be
there probably in about a decade
if he doesn't do much else yeah if he
gets the house paid off that house will
probably be worth 500 and his
you know his 210 he'll be adding to it
during that decade and it'll be growing
and doubling on its own
because he's got it invested i hope in
good growth stock mutual funds so he'll
be right there
yeah the hard thing and we've received
this call so many times or some version
of it whenever i've hosted with you but
the
the hard thing is when you get close to
the finish line when you get close to
either paying off your last debt if it's
just consumer debt
or your house if that's the baby step
that you're on you get so antsy to do it
to be completely debt free that you
start looking at ways to fast forward it
and say okay how can i take money out of
my retirement to get it paid off quicker
and then i'll rebuild my retirement but
that's the reason i think it's this good
reminder that's the slow and steady wins
the race you want both you don't want to
sacrifice one
to be able to fast forward with other
you're still going to get there it's not
that you're not going to be able to pay
off the house
but it's i think some people and we've
had that call even with coombs tumor
debt should i take money out of my
retirement to
you know pay off this last debt we're
like no you know you want to make sure
that you are still letting that money
grow
and not paying the penalties on it you
know when i went broke in my 20s
one of the things i did was i wanted to
talk to old
rich people i'd been young and rich i
didn't want his opinion right it didn't
work out well
i want to talk to people with no hair
and gray hair that had money
and talked to old rich people and so
how did you do it and um
they knew what i was looking for they
knew i was looking for a magic pill
quick
they knew i was looking for a uh you
know jack and the beanstalk i need the
beans right
i need i need the magic i need the
special sauce i need the recipe
and more than one time i would have an
old person
kick back in their chair across their
arms and say something like
well you know the best way to get rich
quick
is don't yeah you're like that is not
what i wanted to hear
we mean don't get rich no don't get rich
quick that's the best way to get that's
the quickest way
to build wealth is don't get rich quick
because get rich quick leads you into
stupidity
the bible says he who hastens to be rich
will not go unpunished
if you're in a hurry you're not going to
go unpunished
get rich quick always lead you to broker
not to richer
there's no shortcut to any place that's
worth going
it's common sense it's not popular in an
instant culture
but it's the truth this is the ramsey
[Music]
chef
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice christy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we take your questions about your
life and about your money mike
is in pensacola florida to start off
this hour hey mike how can we help
hey dave and kirsty thanks for taking my
call how are y'all doing better than we
deserve what's up
well uh my wife and i are debt free
minus our house
we have an emergency fund we're about to
start investing in a 401k
and don't worry we do not own beanie
babies
we're good so i'm calling
about our home we're looking to relocate
to a
better school district and a safer
neighborhood and
you know real estate of course and this
market's crazy i know nothing about it
so we're looking to see if we should
sell now and buy
later being that we have the available
funds for a down payment
and we have the
place to live in the interim for free my
father-in-law's house he's being very
generous
um as far as future predictions will the
market go down later should we sell our
house go live with him and then buy
later what are your thoughts on that
i do not think this is a bubble
okay and that would be the only way it
would go down
i think the i think the craziness will
slow
and the rate of increase in prices will
slow
but i don't think this is a false bubble
that's going to course correct and the
house prices in pensacola florida are
going to go down dramatically
anytime in the next decade
yeah what that means is as you step out
of the market
every day you wait to get back in the
prices are going up for the rest of your
life
so it's definitely not a good idea to
sell now and buy later it's a good idea
to sell now and buy now
sounds like it nothing nothing nothing
wrong with that because it's an even
swap you're going to get the benefit of
the heated market on the sale
and you're gonna uh have the problem of
the ben of the heated market on the buy
so i'm curious about this dave because
we we got some calls like this last week
and i was talking to you about this even
off air
but are you thinking there's gonna be
any kind of dip because right now like
nashville specifically with
these cash buyers coming from california
so it's so much
people are paying so much over appraisal
and list price you're not seeing that go
down you're thinking it's just going to
level out and then
keep going i mean i'm curious about this
because we we hear about this all the
time the only thing that dropped
in 2008 2008 first time in
my 35 years of having a real estate
license that
prices across the nation went down it's
the only time i've ever seen it
was in 2008. now i've seen particular
markets
bubble up and pop and those have to do
with
particular things in those markets uh
but
you know florida does not have any of
those issues i don't you know
for instance i'll give an example i
don't know what's going to happen in
california
yeah because there's a mass exodus
people are leaving
there's there's a stream of u-hauls of
interstate
going down the interstate leaving the
state as fast as they can possibly flee
and so uh and they're going to texas
tennessee florida
uh and buying houses and so what's that
going to do to that real estate market
yeah eventually if enough of that
continues
mathematics tells us that that will hurt
prices in california
it hasn't yet california's quite hot
you put a house on the market you'll
sell in three days right now in l.a and
so
it's not like all these people leaving
have affected there's that gummy people
there that
you know that you you take a while to
empty the state you know and so
but they are they are pouring out of
there for sure and
uh those of us that are in the markets
that they are coming to know it
yeah i mean we go out here at the
commercial breaks right here
and uh you know we i i haven't been
out of this room to go out and meet
people at a commercial break i don't
think a single time
in uh five months that i didn't meet
somebody from california that's here
looking at houses
i mean every dad gum and so that's an
example of a particular market
that has unique problems in that case
created by the governor
uh but uh and because covet is not worse
in california than it is in tennessee in
texas
and so it's just absolute bs but the uh
uh but the bottom line is you know and
we've seen this before in other markets
where
um you know something unique happens a
a a a a a
manufacturing plant shuts down and it
was a that
labor base was a big part of that market
then you can see that market correct
but overall just because it's going up
does not mean it's going to come down
matter of fact you have a hard time
proving that you know i i can think back
again i got my real estate license in
1978 i have seen
very few times that you've seen prices
go down
from where they were four months before
and stay down for more than 20 seconds
yeah i just wasn't sure if it was such a
unique situation because of the
amount of overpaying yeah well they're
overpaying
but are they if enough of them are going
to set that new if enough of them are
doing it that is now the price that's
the new bar yeah
and so the definition when i went
through appraisal class and when i was
getting my degree in real estate
the definition of value of market value
is what a willing buyer
is able is willing to give a willing
seller where neither party is in duress
so in other words if you're buying a
foreclosure that's someone in duress you
wouldn't count that in an appraisal
but if two perfectly healthy situations
and they're paying a whole lot even more
than asking price
then you know where we're getting
multiple offers on a property and that
kind of stuff you know put it on the
market you get 30 offers in a weekend
those kinds of stories are happening all
over then that is the new value so when
people say
i'm not going to overpay for a house
they're not overpaying that's the new
well i mean you know you're you're
overpaying what it's what it's what it
would have brought two months ago right
right right and you're overpaying what
it would have brought monday yeah
but by tuesday yeah i don't know yeah
because
these prices are being driven up by this
supply because what has happened is with
the lumber shortage right
it's driven the price of lumber up the
cost of new housing is going up new
housing is also
more harder to get out of the ground and
so we have
we have an inventory problem and so
anytime there's a shortage of
anything and there's more people chasing
that thing than there is thing
you that's a supply demand curve from
the seventh grade economics class it
drives price up yeah
that even works with beanie babies
[Laughter]
when too few when too few people i mean
when a big bunch of dollars are chasing
too few things
yeah then those things go up anything
that has scarcity
in other words you'd always see the
price go up and so what will happen is
is this market will calm down as the
inventory gets rebuilt
as the lumber factories get to build and
get to making lumber again at the same
pace or an increased pace to offset this
and the prices come back are they at
least the lumber prices will come back
down
that i do think but that's not going to
necessarily affect real estate values
overall so anyway yes i i don't have any
problem with you buying right now
or selling right now but i would do both
of whatever you're going to do
get out of the market whatever you're
going to do i mean it's uh
i'm enjoying watching the real estate
that i own go way up in value
it's just awesome yeah kind of kind of
like it
so you know and that's that's the stuff
so my goodness yeah that's what i would
do i think it's time for you to move sir
and i would and i would buy when you
move
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five nick is with us in new york
city hi nick how are you
hey dave christie thanks for taking my
call sure how can we help
uh so i'm feeling a little stuck because
of prices in new york city so
um i'm 24 years old i just started
working as a software engineer about
six months ago and right now i live in
my grandmother's house um
she's graciously like allowed me to live
here for almost nothing since college
which i you know really appreciate um
but i'm definitely ready to move out
so um what i want to do is buy a condo
with that 20
down to avoid pmi but because of prices
in new york i'm not sure if i'll
be able to afford that down payment for
like another three years or
if i run with friends like that would
just push the savings goal like further
down the road so
i need a little advice on what i should
do there
what are you making so
uh it's gonna be about 100 growth and uh
it's like 6k per month after taxes yeah
no not not bad for 24 man well done
got a great career ahead of you you're
obviously
not only a software engineer you're
obviously a good one well done
uh very cool yeah you are in a very very
expensive
uh real estate market at least for now i
don't know that it will remain that way
i think delaying buying in new york city
would be a real good idea right now
because that is one of the markets that
we may see some price adjustment
because of the you know the collapse of
so many businesses in the area
and the collapse of the economy in the
area and um
so and the number of people leaving the
market so i you know
i personally would not be in a hurry
to buy there um and so i think saving
some money is a good idea
and um you know uh
how did you end up uh where are your
parents how did you end up with your
grandmothers
so my family lives in georgia uh but my
grandmother has a house in new york and
uh
it was easy for me to get to college you
know if i lived up here so
um you know everything just worked out
for me to stay
in new york but she lives in the same
home
uh yeah this is like her summer house
she
uh goes back to the caribbean uh you
know for
half the year so right now she's
enjoying the warmth
down there hmm okay so you have six
months a year that she's not there
roughly give or take
right but um we do like have other
tenants in the house um so like some of
the rooms are being rented and
um it's like i do live with people it's
you know i'm ready to get out of my own
you know at 24 and uh
you know kind of start lifeing myself so
okay go wrench or something
it's not gonna it's not gonna delay you
that much your career is not you
three years from now you're not gonna be
making a hundred grand anymore
you're gonna be making more don't you
think
yeah definitely yeah considerably more
you should be on a pretty heavy uptick i
don't know christy what are you thinking
well it's whenever people ask questions
about should i do this and
some type of sacrifice it's like it's
not bad that you're living there but you
said yourself you're ready to move out
and you're 24 years old you're a young
man you want independence and i don't
blame you
so to dave's point it's not going to set
you that much back financially whenever
you're ready to buy he wouldn't you
wouldn't buy right now anyway
and then in the meantime for those three
years you have the dignity of your own
place and doing your own thing and
paying a little bit of rent and i think
it's going to be worth it on the journey
to you
to get to be out on your own so there
are some sacrifices that's like yeah
let's make this sacrifice because we're
gonna be able to save some money there's
other ones like
hey this isn't gonna set us back that
much but it's gonna give us the
independence and dignity
along the way and that's worth it i
think this is one of those things
we need to find you need to find
something fairly inexpensive to rent
we're not trying to spend a whole bunch
of money here because the more you spend
on rent the
less you're going to have for a down
payment so that part of your equation is
actually correct
but is it going to slow you down or keep
you from buying because you came out and
you know got a rental no so i'm going to
look for something inexpensive we're not
trying to make a statement with your
rental property quite
if you do make a statement the statement
is i'm cheap
that's the statement you're going for
yeah it's not the uh i'm cool
don't don't make an i'm cool statement
with where you go to live all right
and uh and don't justify it and don't
rationalize it and don't go well it's
to eric and don't give me all that crap
because the more you spend on rent
the less you're going to have for the
down payment the longer it's going to
take you to buy
and we don't want to do that but i think
it's worth it for you to
just in your personal development to go
ahead and make that move i agree with
christy
so hey thank you for the call open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five also in new york city
mike is with us hey mike how are you
hey better than i deserve dave thank you
sure how can i help
sure uh so i have a question for you uh
i did something a few months ago that i
know you would advise against
but uh it was before i found your
podcast so don't be mad at me
i'm not mad at you it didn't hurt me
that's true
so i did a cash out finance uh when the
rates went real low
and i was able to drop my mortgage rate
uh over a full point
and i figured hey while i'm at it why
not take out some extra cash to have
but um you know now i have this extra
debt that i have to carry so my question
is
should i go ahead and repay this thing
back and pretend like it never happened
or should i try to invest it um i got it
at a pretty low rate
um i'm just trying to see what i should
do with it
well i agree with you i wouldn't have
done that but now we're there
so we're not gonna we're that's water
under the bridge that milk is spilled
so um so you're out of debt except this
home
uh no i'm on baby steps four five and
six um
and you've got your emergency fund in
place and you're already putting 15
not counting this money and so
regardless of where the money came from
if you have a pile of money and you're
in four five and six
you would say you're going to use it on
four five and six
four is underway you have children yes
okay is there college fund underway oh
yeah it sure is uh
you know still saving towards it but
they have a good amount for themselves
okay then baby step six is pay off the
house early right
right exactly and so we would use if you
got a bonus equal to the amount in your
savings in excess of your emergency fund
you would throw it at the house wouldn't
you
yes i would yeah so i just thought at
the house yeah the problem with you know
i mean my thing was the closing costs
were about 20 000
so i feel like i'm just basically you
know kind of throwing that money away
uh yeah every time i do something stupid
and it costs me money i call it stupid
tax
yeah but that you can't get that money
back
no that's true i just uh you know i just
what i did was i put the money in a
mutual fund for now
um to try to let it go somebody had
already had it it doesn't matter
that's just not that's not a path that
people use to build wealth it doesn't
work
and so we don't you know never
i've never talked to a millionaire said
i borrowed on my house as much as i
could possibly borrow my entire life and
i refinanced it off and took cash out
and put it in a mutual fund and that
made me rich i've never talked to a
single millionaire that told me they did
that
yeah so it's not it's not a methodology
that works so
even though it's a very costly mistake
that that cost is even
you can't undo the cost so the only
question is now do you want to invest in
mutual funds or do you want to work our
plan
and work your baby step six that's the
only question you've got
and then you've got to decide that but
if it's me obviously my plan the thing
we teach here at ramsey is
we'll put excess cash that you've got
this non-retirement funds from any
source
onto the house and pay it off as soon as
possible well and mike i think you know
that
i think you know that probably by
listening to the show and
what i would guess dave and maybe this
is just a hunch but sometimes we
i've done this in my life with whenever
i made a mistake with money is i resist
doing something that's going to make me
face the fact that i lost that money so
it's like putting it back on the house
makes me kind of face the fact that
it's the 20 000. yeah so i'd rather put
it over here because then i can sort of
sideways justify that it wouldn't
totally
be i think i figured out a way to make
it turn the other way and pretend that
20 000 didn't happen if i put it back on
the house it's like oh i've got to
totally face it let's just face it
mike it is it happened bite the bullet
put it on the house and just move on
band-aid off you're right you're right
that's exactly what it is it's
emotionally
yeah you gotta admit it but it's like um
you know uh when you when you the car's
gone down in value
i don't know whether to sell it well
it's gone down in value
when you sell it you admit it right you
know
that's it that's the same kind of thing
that's the same issue exactly you
nailed that well done this is the ramsey
chef
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today i am dave ramsey your host
this is the ramsey show
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free
stage nathan and alison are with us hey
guys how are you
good how are you dave great if you're on
the debt free stage it must mean
you're debt-free how much do you pay off
uh we paid off 124 thousand how long did
this take
um about 30 months good for you and your
range of income during that time
so we started at about 70 000 that was
nate when he graduated
and then i graduated and i it was about
120
000 and then we ended up door dashing on
the side and then i picked up a lot of
extra
hours at my job and then we ended at
about 140. wow
doubled your income yeah with all that
the door dashing the extra hours hard
work everything
what do you guys do for a living i'm a
nurse
and i'm a mechanical engineer very good
two great careers and
yeah you do have the ability to pick up
some extra work particularly during
this 30 months wow cray-cray time
yeah wow what kind of debt was 124 000
it was mainly student loans and then in
including that we had a small credit
card loan and then a small
car loan okay so what started this whole
journey
so back in uh college you know as i was
getting ready to graduate i got a new
internship at the
job i'm currently working at so in with
that internship it includes some
benefits and some of that was you know
like a 401k
plan and things like that quickly
realized i don't know
anything about uh investing or money
management
and so um went to google said i got
i got to learn more about this kind of
thing so uh
found your guys's program uh started
listening to it
and the more i listened to it i you know
i started making more sense
you know i followed the baby steps and
you know quickly realized oh my we're
doing this out of you know out of order
you know
right so yeah we're jumping out of order
by trying to jump into investment we got
to tackle these loans before we
you know dive into that so so with that
um we followed the baby step plan um
started you know we wanted to live like
a you know broke college kid
you could keep living like that while we
made our new income so
so i introduced that to allison and then
she had some thoughts of her own on that
yeah i um i was not really on board so i
had heard of you actually i remember in
high school
my parents at the time were taking fpu
and all i had heard was your name and
that they had mentioned they were never
going to co-sign a loan for any of us
kids and i was
like so sad i was like like who is this
dave guy like i do not like him
that's the only thing that's the only
thing that i'd heard about you
i love it so then when nate had
mentioned it
i was like i no like i don't want to do
that like everything i've heard
about him is terrible like but then he
started showing
all he says is no no no no yeah so
um he he started trying to convince me
and it took some time but i
realized that you're not all that bad
how many people have that story dave oh
there's a lot
to know me is to love me but from a
distance oh it's a problem
that's awesome that's awesome what was
the hardest part like once you decided
to commit y'all are both on the same
page what was the hardest part about
making that change um i feel like for
probably both of us staying
focused um we have both started this as
soon as we graduated so all of like our
friends from college were
just like starting their jobs making
more money and
when you make more money you want to buy
a house buy a car all that stuff
and it's very easy for us to want to do
that too but um
we realized that that was not the end
goal and
yeah staying focused for sure yeah and
just remembering like i said that just
to be patient
focused that you know we didn't get into
this debt overnight you know it
you know we picked it up it's not going
to just disappear overnight either so
we're in the business of
crock pots not microwaves so there you
go okay how long you all been married
uh almost two years okay so you started
this process
so we were engaged in yeah we he kind of
did on his own for a little bit
and then i got on the page after that so
i made him an unfun
date
[Laughter]
one more time that dave ramsey caused
her to be denied something i love it
that's great way to go you guys i'm so
proud of you
how's it feel feels good if yeah it
feels weird still like
it's um we live like broke college kids
for so long
and i feel like it's um hard to remember
like hey if you want to get that more
expensive thing it's okay now because
you're not free like
you can do that yeah we got some room in
the budget too yeah yeah because you're
both making really good money now
right and you started this process you
were just starting your careers yeah and
and you hadn't even entered the nursing
world yet so yeah pretty incredible
so now you're sitting with a you know
100 and a half income
probably from this point forward and no
payments in the world you will do
whatever you want to do right
yes sir i love it well congratulations
you guys thank you
all right so when people ask you how'd
you do that what do you tell them the
key is
um to remember the end goal and
to anything like it's it's short term so
um there is an end and you can do it um
and that anyone can do it it's not a way
of life yeah
yep just live like no one else so that
later i can live and give like no one
else yeah yep and just staying focused
on that budget you know
you you know you create a plan come up
with a plan and
part of that plan is probably going to
include a budget and sticking to it and
holding yourself accountable
yeah well both of you are in career
fields where
you know you enter a a a process
of some kind whether it's a prescription
a
you know a pharmacology thing or whether
it's a series of mathematical formulas
that cause a bridge to be able to stand
up or whatever you said mechanical
engineering but correct maybe not but i
mean you're still
you know you get a result from having
done a certain thing
and so following a plan to uh to get the
positive result is both
how you're both trained academically
right so it's easy it's easy in that
regard because it's just the way your
brains are wired up yeah so now you just
apply to the next thing right
yeah and uh see how how wealthy we can
become and how generous we can become
it's going to be so awesome you guys are
incredible great job so
what are you uh what 27 28 we're 26.
26. wow and completely debt-free
way to go guys who was your biggest
cheerleaders
um our parents but to be honest we
didn't have a lot of cheerleaders a lot
of people
looked down on us honestly and thought
that this was weird
so many people told us like you guys are
so young you're never going to be
debt-free for stuff like why would you
even want to be debt-free
like that's not normal and i feel like
we would go home and talk about it
together
and it would almost get us more fired up
like this is going to happen and now it
happened
and it's awesome to say that and that's
right and all those people
that have all those payments you don't
have those payments all those people
that thought you were crazy
they get payments you don't have yeah
they're gonna start coming around now i
want to know how you did it can you
teach us how to do that yeah that's what
they're gonna that's the next thing
that's gonna happen
plus plus mom and dad who refuse to
co-sign for any loans
they are super excited about this right
now they're going touchdown baby
touchdown
they're like welcome back welcome back i
love it
well well done you guys very very well
done we got a copy of rachel cruz's book
know yourself know your money
her latest new york times bestseller and
uh it is an incredible book you'll enjoy
it so we're so proud of you guys
congratulations
yeah all right it's nathan and alison
rockford
illinois wow 124 000
paid off in 30 months making 70 up to
140
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
awesome congratulations you guys i love
it
that's amazing the bible says no
discipline seems pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
the ability to delete pleasure for a
greater good living like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else
adults devise a plan and follow it
children
do what feels good there's emotional
maturity to people who learn how to
sacrifice for a greater goal and there's
such a theme today in this slow and
steady the sticking with it focusing
over time sticking with it sticking with
it sticking with it
and how it pays off it's not this quick
win it's not this all of a sudden you
flip a switch and it's easy there's not
a magic pill like we've talked about in
business or finances or life
but if you stick with it then you yield
the results the harvest of righteousness
we're talking about we're talking about
whether it's in your finances or even in
your character
over time the discipline pays off
well and it becomes second nature yeah
it becomes
your new way of living it gets easier
that's right it drills new
grooves in your brain that's right and
you have a whole different
the neuroscience backs it up you know so
it's just beautiful well done you guys
they can do anything now yeah 26.
yeah they can do anything 26. this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
doing your taxes sucks
but what makes it even worse is that
trusted brands
like turbo tax are actually screwing you
with shady sales and marketing tactics
that are designed to put more of your
money in their wallet
so we decided to expose this 800 pound
gorilla in an all-new podcast called
the fine print the hidden truth
to keeping you broke now this
podcast the fine print is going to be
done every so often
george campbell and i do the first one
we're going to pull back the curtain on
turbotax and show you exactly
how they're taking advantage of you plus
we'll teach you a better easier way to
do your taxes
one that keeps you from going deep in
debt now here's the thing
the fine print the new podcast called
the fine print is going to constantly be
doing
exposes on these industries that are
screwing people
and we're going to dig into them and uh
it's our little investigative reporting
arm
here and we're going to dig into these
things and show you what the
fine print says and you can get a sneak
peek of the first episode
in the ramsey show podcast feed on
spotify
the ramsey network app apple podcasts or
wherever you listen to podcasts so we're
going to give you a little sneak
peek and then we'll do the official
launch of the fine
print podcast the new podcast that we're
doing from ramsey networks called the
fine print
because that's the old saying they get
you in the fine print right yep and no
one reads it
the other thing about the whole the tax
companies is i think a lot of the
average consumer looks to tax companies
to say oh well this is a
trusted source this is someone that is
objective they're going to help me
they're experts in money taxes whatever
and they
they then look to them for advice they
get bad advice they make bad decisions
and they don't realize what's going on
behind the scenes so i think this is so
powerful that you guys are
are pointing this out and teaching
people this yeah well they sell a lot of
loans yeah and they don't
but the advertisers they're in the
lending business more than the tax prep
business tax
prep business is just a front door but
when someone's coming there they're not
they're not on guard against it
is what i'm saying versus like a credit
card company would be more on guard
against and so it happened so
sneakily and so you don't see it
happening oh they're just helping me oh
this is what i need to do they're
showing me what i need to do and this is
what i need to do
no that's not what you need to do all in
the fine print brian is with us in
rochester new york hey brian
welcome to the ramsey show hey
thanks for your wisdom really appreciate
all that you do our pleasure how can we
help
so i'm in kind of a conundrum and i
wanted to
get your advice
i have about 98 thousand dollars in
cash on hand 150 000 in a retirement
account
51 years old i owe 61 000
on my business mortgage
that's the only debt that i have other
than
a couple of car loans and i'm wondering
if i should
pay off the business debt or invest that
money
into my retirement i'm afraid that i
just don't have enough
save for retirement what do you make
our bring home is around 75.
okay how long you had the business
too long okay what's happening
that means 20
uh 29 years i mean too long i mean like
you don't want it anymore what do you
mean
uh well just kind of burned out on it
what are you gonna do with it
um i mean at this point
really my only choice is already either
sell the real estate
and go into other ventures or just
continue
doing what i've been doing and how old
are you 51.
what's your business it's retail
what what burned you out what burned you
out
uh just 29 years of doing it and not
being as far as i thought i should be at
this point
the 75 thousand year income or is your
wife also work outside the home
that's combined what does she make
the right around bring home is right
around
15. okay so she works part-time
no she's full-time but a lot of the
money goes towards uh
health insurance
okay well there are several things
i'm going to answer several questions
that were not asked
i'm not going to be 51 and be going for
the next 20 years until i'm 71 i'm going
to work
a business that i'm sick of and that i
don't make much money at
why would you do that what's the real
estate worth
um probably around 200.
yeah i think you'd be better off being a
landlord and get a job
or you'd be better off starting another
venture of some kind like you said
what would you do christie renting yeah
i think i think you have an opportunity
to rethink things
and and you called in about paying your
mortgage paying
you know paying off a debt but there's a
bigger question at play to your point
dave i'm going to answer questions you
didn't ask
i think that the the assumption that you
have to keep doing this and be unhappy
when you're 51 is
is not an accurate assumption and then
an opportunity
to say what do i want to do with the
next 20 years 30 years
and and this is obviously not the path
so what do you want to do well that's
going to help answer the question of
what you do today with your business
with your money
with your debt etc but don't just make a
decision today based on well
i've got this debt i've got this cash i
guess i should pay it off and just keep
plugging along going through the motions
in your life you're not
you're not happy you're not making great
money at it that you
what you want to be doing what you're
proud of what you're excited about you
can hear it in your voice you're not
excited about it
so what what would excite you what would
you do if you could do something
different
so i venture i have uh the money that
we've the hundred thousand that we
we have cash on hand we've earned by
flipping some houses some real estate
that we've
bought and held and rented and then sold
and then up market
and that's what really kind of you know
motivates me kind of that's really where
kind of my heart is cool and i can do
that
i can do that anywhere and that's the
luxury that we have is we can kind of go
anywhere our house is paid off um
you know some inherently yeah so the the
real estate that's worth 200
000 is that what the 61 is owed on yeah
okay all right and the business has
absolutely no value you don't think
um i really i just don't think it does
it's retail
um floor covering and um there's
you know in in a 30 mile radius there's
probably
20 to 25 different locations yeah but a
competitor wouldn't want another
location in your area
um they may buy our vet our customers
but that's about the extent of it i
think
yeah maybe i'm underselling it well make
sure of that before you
yeah before you understand it because
your burnout so you're looking at it
with those eyes you're looking at it
with burnout eyes
there's someone else may look at it
agreement that says they can't talk
about it but i would talk to a
competitor
that you think is a little that's doing
well that is excited in the market and
just say hey if i was to uh
if you if you were to look at this how
would you value it and would you
consider it and let's just let don't you
don't name a price and you don't walk
around with your lip stuck out you say
you know just just poking around here
i'm i'm really not that interested in
selling but i might if the price was
right
and i want to know what you the kind of
number you'd put on it and then maybe
he's going to offer you something that
makes your jaw drop
okay and then sell the real estate and
put 140 000 with your 100 000 and do
flips
i'm having fun though yeah
i mean so my biggest
uh my biggest concern is the lack of
um retirement at 51.
if you're flipping houses and making
money you can invest it
right you got all kinds of time to
invest if you just get with it
but right you know dude you know
truthfully you're just you're you're
burned up
and just just your voice tone even
it changed when you started talking
about the houses yes the first time the
first time we heard energy in your voice
yes
your voice audibly changed and when you
talked about that
you can hear it and that's what's gonna
that's what's also gonna fix the
retirement thing
it's not it's not slogging it out here
on something now if you were making 250
000
a year on this business and it was going
to take four years to sell it or
something
i'd i'd slow your butt down until you
suck it up and man up and get it done
but this thing you need to roll out of
this in the next six months and you put
that commercial property on the market
you need to start flipping houses and
take some of that flip money
and invest it fully fund your retirement
and uh you're gonna have plenty of
retirement and you're going to make some
money
and you're having fun again that's
exactly what i do i pay off the cars
today
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the bus
[Music]
hey guys this is kelly associate
producer for the ramsay show
did you know that over 16 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listed on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
daveramsey.com
[Music]
show
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i
am dave ramsey your host christy wright
ramsey personality is my co-host today
we're here answering your questions
about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five
dave is with us in huntington west
virginia hi dave
welcome to the ramsey show yeah i
appreciate you having me
love listening to you guys and i
appreciate your brutal honesty
that's his special thing it would be
brutal to be dishonest
now i appreciate you guys hey i'm a w-2
employee at the va medical center
in huntington love that job um and work
in the medical field
and also uh staff surgery centers with
anesthesia under a 1099.
uh maybe a quick crazy questions but i
put off the taxes to the end of the year
on my 10.99
and whatever my account says i owe i put
into my sep
instead crazy not crazy
don't do it your sep is only a deduction
it's not a tax credit
okay that's alrighty so when you put if
you put ten thousand dollars in your sep
it doesn't save you ten thousand dollars
on taxes
if you put ten thousand dollars in your
sep and you're in a thirty percent tax
bracket it saves you three thousand
dollars on taxes
so you're still going to owe seven
thousand in taxes
i appreciate that yeah okay so you
advocate obviously paying the quarter
leasing
yes yeah you're gonna be you're gonna be
penalized and fined if you do not
pay your quarterlies anyway uh now what
you can do
if you want to do if you want to just
calculate it is the is the 1099 steady
is it predictable
yes yes you could just up your
withholding on your w-2 job
for enough to cover it oh okay
fair enough and so you know let's say
what do you make at your 1099 job
a year uh well four businesses four
business partners
we've probably got an ar of 750 to a
million
i'm sorry you make 750 000 1099 income
no no
no no no our ar is that i misunderstood
the question no mine is probably
80. my cut would be 80 000 a year on
that
on the 1099 alone
i'm at 10.99 yes yes so you have 80 000
that you have not paid taxes on if you
don't file your quarterlies okay and
what do you make at your w-2 job
um right at 200. okay
all right so let's just say the taxes
i'll just make up a number
when you sit with your tax person and
they say the taxes on the 80 grand
is 24 000 okay okay
then you would just increase your w-2 by
2 000 a month
which is 24 000 a year and then you
would have already paid your taxes on
your 80
and you would not be susceptible i don't
think
ask your tax person but i don't think
you'd be susceptible to a penalty at
that point
but if you've done if you've made 80
more than two years in a row and you
don't pay quarterly or you don't somehow
have proper withholding done
you're going to be penalized for not
doing your quarterlies
and i just saving it up and paying it at
the end of the year is not an option
it is an option but it's an expensive
option to use so
you need to get a good tax pro in your
corner and either do quarterlies
or do what i'm talking about if you
don't get penalized the way i'm talking
about
i'm not positive about that part of it
but that's another way to handle the
math
philip is with us and spoke in hi philip
welcome to the ramsay show
thanks for having me great how can i
help
yeah so i'm looking at a new job
opportunity that's i'll be starting here
soon and the new job they are exempt
from social security so i don't
contribute they don't either which i'm
kind of happy
about and they take the portion that i
would contribute to social security and
they put it into a state pension
and then i would continue to do my 15
which i've been doing at my previous job
into my roth as well as 401k
um do i need to worry about not getting
social security at all and then
adjusting a little bit extra into
retirement or am i good just
doing the 15 and then letting them dump
the money into the pension
you're good with that part because
here's the thing you've already paid
into social security you're going to get
some
but social security has a negative rate
of return
you never get out as much as you put in
much much less any interest okay that
makes sense and so
but you if you've already been paying in
for several years you're going to get
something
upon retirement that's what they told me
to yeah they said you'll get based off
what you paid the last 15 years in the
workforce
yeah you'll get paid into it you'll
probably get the full amount or close
i mean by the time you get to 65 but so
if you stay in this job until 65
um you know and you put in 15 that's
going to end up being your biggest
by far your biggest return not the
pension and not social security
okay that makes sense do it thanks man
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five christy wright
ramsey personality is my co-host robert
is in nashville
hey robert how can we help hey we're
dave how are you doing
better than i deserve how can we help
so i'm teaching a financial literacy
class to a youth group at church
middle school and the curriculum has
been given to us of what we are to teach
and part of the curriculum is teaching
uh the
individuals how to go into debt
basically how to borrow money
and use credit wisely and i'm kind of
morally
torn about teaching that portion of the
curriculum but
it's kind of mandatory so how do i go
about doing that and still feeling
morally right about it have you talked
to anybody about it
no you're the first ones
well i mean here okay let me let me ask
you this because i don't want to assume
something
is this a church a bible-believing
church
yes okay so they don't think that the
bible is allegory
they they are a bible-believing church
no
not at all not at all but yes they are a
bible-believing believing church yeah
okay
so you know if you were to sit down with
the people at the church and go
uh it says nowhere in scripture not a
single place it doesn't say a positive
thing about debt
it is wrong for us to use in a church
that believes the bible
to be teaching teenagers to go into debt
and the proper way to do that when the
bible doesn't teach that
right what kind of reaction would you
get
um i would probably get a positive
reaction
but you know they chose the curriculum
and
you know it was a book written by
whomever
that we're working out of so i'm
thinking about just actually leaving
that whole portion out of the
curriculum well how about we just we'll
give you some curriculum for
free okay yeah don't sidestep it robert
i mean not from a communication
standpoint not from a
curriculum standpoint like this is a
great opportunity
for you to communicate exactly like dave
said what the bible says about this
and lead up in your organization
about this topic of finances and you
don't come in like a bulldozer
pointing fingers placing blame you're
saying hey here are my convictions
here's what i've studied here's what i
believe here's a curriculum that
is proven that is biblically placed
here's what it says in the bible
and you have all these different angles
that you're able to communicate and have
a conversation you could lead to actual
change in your church
versus just leaving that lesson out yeah
i agree i don't know if you're going to
do it or not but i'll offer you
curriculum for free to teach them out of
our high school curriculum
i'll have kelly pick up and get your
contact information and if you want it
and we'll teach that instead we'll give
it to you and
that'll solve the problem um but i think
you need to sit down with leadership
because leadership's not making a good
call here
it's not a matter of being mean about it
it's just being kind and open and
con conflict in a healthy organization
is a good thing
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
wow nearly 30 years ago we started this
show
on a tiny little bankrupt radio station
here in nashville
we talked about the same stuff that we
talk about now
we sound a little more country
living on a budget getting out of debt
building wealth about 15 years ago
a guy walked into my office that was
working for us and he was kind of one of
these
mad scientist type guys and he said
um we need a podcast and i said
what's a podcast and uh
nobody had a podcast and he said you
need a podcast i said we don't need a
podcast i've never even heard of a
podcast why do i need a podcast and we
talked about it and laughed about it and
um we figured out we could start one it
wasn't that the heavy lifting that we
could basically take this show and put
it on a podcast the radio show that we
were doing every day anyway
what we call sawdust in the business or
it's the stuff you're making anyway you
might as well use it for lots repurpose
it for lots of different things
we also put it on siriusxm and we also
put it a lot of other places over there
youtube now that kind of stuff but uh
what's interesting is the ramsay show is
one of the top podcasts in the world if
you didn't know
consistently ranking in the top four
five six podcasts
on apple and uh we
have become the fifth show in history
uh about a week ago there's only four
other shows that have done it before us
and we're the fifth show in history
to now have had one billion
downloads of this podcast that's
incredible that's
mind-blowing we said when that slide
went up this morning in our staff
meeting i mean i
i can't wrap my head around that our
people's they couldn't cheer because
they couldn't get their mouth closed
yeah they were jaw-dropped yeah billion
downloads of this podcast
i that's a lot yeah
that's mind-blowing you know only four
other shows have done it and there's
obviously the uh four of the five
four or the five or six shows that are
bigger than this show and do a great job
as well
obviously in this in the podcast world
and uh
what's interesting is over the years
we've added up every year we add up um
what the debt free screams uh
have done and how much they have paid
off and we've added that up now and now
we've helped callers
just on air do debt-free screams
for over 500 million dollars
and that's just the on-air debt free
screams a half a billion
that's just the ones we know about yeah
and so what that means is it's at least
10x
that and um pretty crazy
pretty crazy so uh subscribe and follow
the ramsay show podcast
and uh apparently you won't be by
yourself yeah
on spotify apple google wherever you
listen to podcasts
uh check out all the podcasts in the
ramsey network rachel cruz ken coleman
anthony o'neil christy wright dr john
deloney
uh the new one the fine print that's
coming out
borrowed future the famous podcast on
the student loan
epic failure of the student loans system
and uh pretty pretty stinking incredible
so check it all out at
daveramsey.com and anywhere great
podcasts are you can find the ramsey
network
and of course this being the flagship
show
of that and um
so again a billion downloads thank you
guys out there so much
you guys have blessed us telling your
friends about it obviously and
and listening yourself and i'm glad
we've been able to help you and serve
you
uh to the level that to that level it's
pretty pretty
amazing to us that blows my mind i can't
even calculate what that means a
billion downloads a billion
wow ah mike is in indianapolis hey mike
welcome to the ramsey show how can
christy and i help
hi so this is kind of surreal talking to
you on the phone
okay glad you're here brother for my
family
um but i need to hear it from your lips
okay um over the last
year my wife and i have paid off all of
our debt with the exception of the
mortgage
and eight thousand dollars in student
loans okay
since then um we have been able to put
about eighteen thousand dollars in the
bank
just because i was off the covet for
seven weeks and it scared us
okay now we need some upgrades to our
house
including new windows we bought a 45
year old house windows are original to
the home
but i still have 8 000 in student loans
do i write the check and get rid of them
and then do the
improvements to the house or can i go
ahead and give my wife new windows
well you know the answer you know they
have you tell us the answer
what's the answer mike tell us
the biggest problem is that in the
winter where we live is so
rural we have propane heat and the
windows leaked so bad that it cost us
yeah how long have you lived there
uh six years when
i know by the way this is what month
it's but it's still cold up here i know
so on
it's not it's not it's not going to be
cold but another month
right so this has nothing we're not even
heading into weather
not gonna work mike okay by the way
by the way what are the windows cost
yeah that's what i was like how much of
the windows because how much have you
got in savings
eighteen thousand and the how the
windows are gonna cost
sixty five hundred okay so what is your
emergency fund fully funded
what should it be three to six months of
expenses three to six months of expenses
should be at three months we would be
right around six thousand dollars
we were very lean okay so eighteen minus
8 is 10
minus 6 for your emergency fund leaves
four why can you not have the windows in
by next fall
i don't know what's your household
income
uh so it's just me we homeschool our
kids what's your household income take
take home is 43 000 but that also
includes um i have a company car
and a company pays for all of my vehicle
maintenance gap everything so i don't
have a travel budget for
for our work very nice okay
well so um but i mean
let i think you ought to put in windows
by the fall
and i think you're gonna have an
emergency i think you're gonna pay off
your student loan today
you keep your emergency fund aside and
anything above your emergency fund will
drag over to a different savings account
and that's the window savings account
you take on an extra job you have a
garage sale you do whatever else to have
the difference
in and have your windows ready to
purchase uh before it gets cold
you know i think mike i think you i
think coveted scared y'all a little bit
i think you stocked up this cash of 18
000
i think you liked having the cushion of
18 000 and now the thought of spending
some of the 18 000
on windows or your debt scares you
because you like having the eighteen
thousand and i just want you know you're
gonna be okay
you can pay off your loans you can get
your windows you can refill your
emergency fund you're gonna be okay it's
gonna be lower than you're used to
because you're used to having this
eighteen thousand
but you have it for that reason to use
it for things you need and you need this
you need to pay off your loans and you
get those windows by fall
and you're still going to have money for
your emergency fund
and you keep filling it up right
alrighty thank you guys so much
you can do it you can do it and she can
do it
you guys are gonna make it and and yeah
you're not you know
so you're gonna have one more month of
coolish weather
and you you're probably gonna survive it
it's pretty amazing he made it for six
years
so i get like that about stuff in my
house
it's like i'm fine it's fine for five
years and then i see it and i just can't
unsee it and i become a one-track mind
and you have to remind yourself i lived
with this for this long we don't need
this right now it's not it did not
become an emergency yesterday because we
decided
oh my gosh the windows you've lived with
it we're going into summer you'll be
fine but sometimes you see something
like oh man you just fixate on it
my next book is going to be called the
death of the drama queen
because there's a drama queen that lives
inside of every one of us it's just the
guy
right there's a drama queen inside of
all of us
we all do that yeah what you talked
about there i've done it
yeah i may have done it this week and
it's just monday right yep
but uh we all have this drama queen that
lives inside of us it's like oh god the
propane is just going out the window
where is he we all do that crap right
yes
and and once we decide we fixate on it
and there's something about this little
child on the cereal aisle that wakes up
and throws a fit
i can't live with those windows another
day and they live inside of us and this
little child makes our decisions it's
like
and we just have this little hissy fit
and that's a southern term sounds
just like yankees don't even know what
that means a hissy fit
it's like a duck fit those are two two
non-yankee terms right there
but it just means your emotions got out
of control because you're immature i'll
help you with that okay
oh my goodness this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america we're glad
you're here open phones
triple eight eight two five five two two
five christy wright ramsey personality
is my co-host brandon is with us in
dallas texas hey brandon how are you
yes sir how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well i hope you haven't called anybody
an idiot today because i want to give
you the first crack at me
we are starting this strong brandon i
can't wait
i've been listening i've been listening
for a couple years that's not too bad
but i should i think i should know the
answer but i just
don't i want to feel like i have like
this unique situation but
anyway i'm a uh i'm not a teacher
anymore i used to be a teacher i taught
for 12
years i'm self-employed for the last two
years
in these last two years i've been making
good money but i haven't put anything
away for retirement
and when i look at you know what i've
made as a teacher as far as retirement
it's just
a little under forty thousand dollars
i'm not really sure how it
how that works you know over over time
but i figured after twelve years i would
have a little bit more than that
anyway um i bought some property
uh i kept it for a year decided i wanted
to
move to be closer to where i work for my
my new job
so i'm in the process of selling that
property
worth about 90 000 and
i have bought some property in the new
city where i live
and so my question is um you know now
that i'm making
decent money and really i'm in no you
know i'd like to build a house
uh in the future but i'm kind of okay
renting for the time being
i'm always worried about retirement so
my question is
with the money that i make from selling
this property
should i you know throw 125 000
into my retirement or should i put that
90 000
towards you know the the new property
that i'm
that i've just bought and you know try
to go ahead and pay that off
what are you making um about 150 pre-tax
wow good for you nice jump
thank you and it's just cell phone
repair computer repair so good for you
okay fairly predictable then that's good
okay and that's that's one thing that
i'm worried about though because i'm
wondering you know
how technology changes you know i'm
that's what i'm kind of worried about
nothing is forever it's okay right
you're gonna you're gonna stay on top of
it and you're gonna find something else
to work on
as whatever you're working on isn't
there anymore we don't work on toasters
anymore but we used to
yes sir and you'll find something else
to work on the guys that used to work on
toasters work on cell phones now so it's
you're gonna be fine you're you're the
guy that's gonna you're gonna figure it
out so
good news is you're making good money so
here's our rule of thumb
we're going to work we work a thing
called the baby steps
and baby step one is a thousand dollars
in the bank you've done that two is
debt-free everything but your house
you've done that right
yes sir three is an emergency fund do
you have an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses
not counting 90 grand i do yes sir good
for you
okay then we're on baby steps four five
and six four is fifteen percent of your
income should be going into retirement
you need to go to daveramsey.com click
on smart vester
get a smart vista pro sit down with them
start loading a couple of roth are you
married
i am not but i do have children okay you
need to start loading a roth ira
how many employees do you have it's just
me
okay then i would look at doing a sep as
well simplified employee pension plan
and between that and a roth you can get
15 of your income going into retirement
with the smartvestor pro
automatically coming out your checking
account every month and it'll just be on
autopilot you want to think about it
again and you're going to retire with a
lot of money how old are you
i'm 38 but can i tell you one more thing
here sure
i guess my fear overall is that
i feel like you know i'm making more
money than i've ever made but my fear is
you know apple or samsung is going to
make a phone that
you can't repair or it doesn't need to
be repaired and i may
have to go back to teaching you're going
to find something else to work on
in the meantime you're going to say 15
of your income into retirement
and baby step 5 is you're going to start
putting something aside for your kids
and baby step 6 is
that you're going to get your home paid
off in this case this land paid off
so that formula tells us that you're
going to put the 90 000
towards your land okay
and you're going to set up these other
accounts so you quit ringing your hands
about the retirement here's the thing
very few people become wealthy with
single deposits
the vast majority of wealthy people did
it monthly
over an extended period of time it was
not a one-time hit
so when you get to 70 years old and you
have 10 million dollars you're not going
to go it's because of that 90 grand
you're going to go it's because of a
steady life of investing
and i had to pivot my business my
business had to change and evolve
because i mean back in art 21 they had
these things called smart
phones you know back before we had the
hologram
you know or what you know what i'm
saying yes sir crap's gonna change right
and you're gonna find something else to
do
and or a modification of what you're
doing still within
that field when i started this business
the internet was not there there was no
such thing
and and the one thing i would add
brandon is let that um
let that change inspire you not
intimidate you
let it inspire you to stay sharp on your
skills and learn new things and be
excited about what you're going to know
how to do in 5-10 years not be scared
that the world's going to move on and
leave you behind and you're not going to
have a job because you're working on
these old phones that no one uses
anymore the toaster
in this example don't don't look at it
like that you can look at this and let
it inspire you like hey i'm going to
stay on the cutting edge of what's going
on
the first guy that works on the new
brand new x or the brand new y
yeah because you're working it because
you're looking for that because you know
that you know 10 years from now you're
not working on a smartphone
i'm a thousand yeah i'm a thousand
percent sure of that
well thank you for the advice i really
appreciate it yeah that's how i would do
it
you that's exactly what i would do i
think you i think your business is as
stable as your ability to continue to
innovate
yep and that's everybody by the way it's
not going to be the rug pulled out from
underneath you
most likely it's going to be you're
going to learn as you go like you did to
get to this point
yeah very few businesses do you just
walk unless you have a single thing with
a single product
now if you bet your life on apple oh you
could get screwed
yeah if you bet your life on google you
could get screwed
back your life on facebook you could get
screwed so don't don't have a business
model that allows yourself to be
completely vulnerable to
any one thing yeah out there any one
vendor any one
a singular process but um
you know you got to have a diversified
approach to it and a constant
mind for innovation and the next thing
but you got to have that in any business
right oh yeah
any business things are about the only
thing you can count on is change
marley is with us marley's in reddington
are reading
california hi marley how are you great
how are you
better than i deserve what's up well i
am currently out on
maternity leave and hey what'd you have
yes i have a boy who's just turned three
months and then we have a daughter who
is about to turn two yay congratulations
man you got a lot of noise in your house
yeah no sleep they are both napping
right now thankfully
um but my question is my husband and i
both um
make fairly good money in our day jobs
i'm a teacher i make
a little over forty five thousand a year
my husband
makes a little over sixty thousand at
his day job but he also owns
uh two small businesses and so you make
a little less than a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars
right now um he did just start a new
business that could potentially
make um he makes 130 or we do
we we okay of that 45 is you
correct okay so 85 is his i got you okay
what's your question yes um my question
is i would really like to
stay home um good and we we've both
kind of talked about it a lot right now
we're debt-free um
we're able to contribute about a
thousand dollars a month extra towards
our mortgage
and like 40 of his income towards
retirement
but we won't be able to do those things
if i stay home that's not what we teach
we don't teach 40 towards retirement
correct yeah we teach 15 towards
retirement until your house is paid off
if you want to stay home you're trading
kids for money
that's a good trade what do you think
yeah you're in a position to be able to
do it you want to do it do it
make the decision to cut back on some
things and make the decision for your
budget to work
and to stick to it but um you know set
up 15
of his income going into retirement
you'll be fine
you're gonna be just fine but don't go
in debt to do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day isaiah 41 13
for i
am the lord your god who takes hold of
your right hand and says to you
do not fear i will help you
julie andrews the original mary poppins
said perseverance
is failing 19 times and succeeding
the 20th
so i grew up on herbie and mary poppins
but i really really like the new one too
oh i haven't seen it yeah i'm seeing it
well it's not brand new i mean it was
just a couple years ago yeah yeah who
was it kelly
emily blunt yeah she did a great job
yeah
um i'm not i'm not cool enough to keep
up with who's in hollywood but um
but she did that was and uh the guy that
played uh
played dick van dyke's role as well was
yeah okay he was fabulous and i'm not
even gonna try to do that but anyway
yeah he did a good job too
so yeah it was fun that's fine that's a
great great old story
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five stafford is with us in
charleston south carolina
hi stafford how are you hey doing great
dave i appreciate you taking my call
sure how can we help um yeah so
me and my fiance are getting married in
july which we're very excited about
yay since thank you since i was a kid my
parents followed your plan and passed
all those values to me and so
i appreciate that um because i've been
debt free since you know out of school
and
um been really just trying to stay on
that one of my life goals is to be
consumer debt-free
great um and so we're getting married
but she's got some credit card debt
and some student loans and so it's not a
matter of if to pay off the credit
cards and the in the student loans but
how to go about doing it
um and so we've got some cash saved up
that we have to pay for the wedding
um as well as we want to do some home
renovations um
but the question was is it worth trying
to settle on some of this credit card
debt
by calling and and settling directly
with the credit cards
uh she's not behind she changed her
minimum payment but she don't know she
doesn't make enough stuff
no they won't they're not going to
settle if you're not behind they're not
going to settle the only reason they
settle is if
if you're in default and they and you're
going to have to screw up her credit to
do that
so women i'm sorry i drove right by
something you're going to pay for the
wedding how much money do you have
i've got about 50 000 in savings right
now
and how much you spend on the wedding
uh we're paying a portion of it so we're
probably putting 15
towards the wedding which leaves 35 and
she has 37.
right so when you come home from the
honeymoon you write a check and pay off
the debt
104. no no no home renovations i heard
you sneak that through there
he did he just and then just to go just
to drive by
she's threatened to push the wedding
back unless you get some stuff
knocked out so i'm a single guy living
at a house from about
so for a while and so yeah well i mean
we're not talking about putting it off
for very long you're going to have zero
debt and you're going to be on a budget
together
and you have your emergency fund in
place you'll be able to save up for home
renovations as your next goal
guys so you're saying don't try to
negotiate just try to
just pay it off and move on well you're
they're not going to negotiate
does she want to pay off this debt yes
okay because this is a this is a we need
to be on the same page with
values and how we handle money in
addition to paying off the debt because
if you pay off the debt and she's still
excited about using credit cards there's
you gotta run into this problem again
no absolutely she's ready to get rid of
it she just she works for a ministry and
isn't making enough stuff
okay so what do you make payments so
i make a hundred a year what is 500 a
week in a
title so she's doing about 28 a year
okay
all right and what's the how much in
whose home is renovating who are we
moving who's your house her house what
it's my house and what does it need how
much you need to spend on it
uh probably about thirty thousand okay
all right and so with a hundred and
something thousand dollar household
income and no debt in the world and you
knowing how to do it
be on a budget and her learning how to
be on a budget and we both have one goal
and that's do some of these renovations
you probably can do them in a few stages
you could start almost immediately on
the first stage
right and debt-free then you're you're
making those renovations debt-free
yeah i don't think the credit card
company is going to settle with you when
you're not behind
i got you and i don't think anybody else
is either and i wouldn't recommend you
put her behind
merely for the purposes of settling um
but i think it's real important that the
two of you lay out a detailed
see all i'm doing is i'm not saying
don't do something
i'm saying doing in a very specific
order
that gives you the least that gives you
the most
money and the least risk
right that's why that's the thing
yeah because i think we're on the same
page in terms of
is wanting to get rid of it it's not in
i it's a good thing i don't know about
credit card settlement i guess it's a
good thing i don't know that but
yeah i just was doing information
well you're trying to get everything
done at once by paying less for the debt
so that you can go and start the home
renovations
which is not a bad question to ask it's
a reasonable question to ask but
here's the thing the reason anyone like
think about if someone owed you money
the only reason you would take less than
what was owed is because you don't think
you're gonna get your money
and you don't think you're gonna get
your money because they haven't been
paying
and so when you you know a lot of these
companies that that for instance they
call themselves debt consolidation
companies they're not
all they do is put you on a payment plan
where you start paying them instead of
the credit
card companies the credit cards get
behind and then they settle on
after they've destroyed your credit and
put you into default
and so i wouldn't set out to destroy i
don't set out to build credit but i
wouldn't set out to destroy it either
not when you have the ability to pay a
bill that is legitimate
i would just pay the bill and then i do
my home repairs as my second order of
business
which by the way your home repairs are
probably all going to be done
within 12 months and a whole bunch of
them are going to be done by christmas
yeah it's not never it's just not right
now it's in this specific order
yeah and that that's a there's a reason
for that so
christy i've done that exercise
a bazillion times with people that i'm
coaching on the air here or otherwise
but sharon and i had to do it you know i
mean she's driving one of these
ugly blue thousand years ago
two-tone blue astro van you remember
those yes
nasty nasty butt little van it was
completely worn out
i mean there was stuff growing in the
thing we had raised children animals
were making homes in it yeah we raised
children in this van and she's like we
and we
you know where the business was starting
to grow and we had a little bit of money
and she's like we need to get a suburban
and i'm like
no i've got this thing at the office we
need to do this thing at the business
you know and
and we got in this big argument yeah are
we going to do this thing at the
business first are we going to invest in
the business are we going to buy stupid
suburban
and you know because i i'm like no i
mean we're going to grow the business
there's no question no we're getting a
suburban there's no question
and finally between the two of us we're
stupid but we finally figured it out
we could do both yeah it was only a
matter of which one went first
and guess what went first we started
with a suburban and then we the next
batch of money
you know that came through we used to
grow the stuff at the office here
and uh but you know it's not no it's
just
which is first yeah it's not like no you
can't do the stuff the business
no you're never gonna get a suburban you
just have to decide the proper or it's
not like no we're not gonna do
renovations or no we're not going to pay
off the debt
right it's just a matter of the laying
out that order and that order
indicates what you value and that's why
you asked that question about what are
what our values are yeah and i think
also whenever you're seeing two people
come together
they're getting married they're so
excited one has had brought debt into
the marriage one has been financially
responsible has no debt
you've got to have some of these
conversations because habits have to
change
it's it's fine you know it's fine if you
didn't have it all together before you
got married
but you need to get on the same page so
that as a married couple
you're making those decisions together
about debt about savings about where and
how you spend and sometimes you have to
wrestle it out like that example matt
and i have had
plenty of those conversations of which
comes first and which is more important
and everybody
speaks into it but the only that's why i
wanted to ask that so i thought okay if
this is the past that's totally fine
we'll make sure it's not going to be the
future
spending habits whenever you're talking
about credit cards yeah we get into
we have to get in lockstep uh especially
a newlywed couple
because you're gonna it's the number one
thing couples fight about
and it's one of the data points we find
with the millionaires
is that they not always but
the vast majority of them i forget the
number
their spouses were on board with them
they're working together they weren't
one of them pulling the other one along
yep yep and uh and they were you know
two adults
yep making decisions about their future
and he's gonna have a lot better time
and she is as well making those home
renovations being debt-free
it's gonna be a lot more fun to pick
stuff out and make decisions yeah yeah
you don't not with credit card debt
hovering over your shoulder yeah
that's a good point that puts us out of
the dave ramsey show in the books we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace
christ jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsay advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you